it looks like Bibi is back after 16
months plotting his return Benjamin
Netanyahu seems to have pulled off his
political Resurrection according to exit
polls the former prime minister is on
trial for bribery and fraud his critics
fear that back in power Netanyahu will
bend the legal system to avoid
conviction
[Applause]
I haven't got a voice but we have your
voice you're wonderful thank you I want
to say to my friends from from the
knesset the heads from the towns the
volunteers those who have gone from town
to Town neighborhood to Neighborhood
house to house and have fought the
results thank you
the far-right Jewish power party is
celebrating a significant breakthrough
they'll be the third largest Block in
Parliament and will likely be king
makers their leader itmal bengavir a man
with a 2007 conviction for inciting
racial hatred wants to run the public
security Ministry
to make a total separation between those
who are loyal to the state of Israel and
we don't have any problem with them and
those who undermine our dear country
it will be the first time ultra
nationalist politicians have held
cabinet positions I believe that once
those people will be part of government
they will realize that the challenge
the issues and also they will have to
realize that they are working under a
liquid-led government
there was a strong turnout in
palestinian-israeli communities but it
wasn't enough to counter the surge in
votes for the far right and help tip the
balance in favor of incumbent prime
minister yilapid
the Netanyahu opposition voted against
everything even the stuff they believed
in even you know extending a law to
Jewish citizens on the West Bank they
voted against it because they believe
they have to bring down the government
there was no sense of national good it
would have been hard before the election
to find anyone who hadn't already made
their mind up about Benjamin Netanyahu I
either love him or loathing so this
election ended up being about getting
the vote and particularly voters who
hadn't passed a ballot in previous
elections and that tactic seems to have
worked but now there are hours days
maybe weeks of negotiations to go on
before a government can be formed
West Jerusalem